une équipe d'élus locaux c'est l'image
et le message que voulait faire passer
les candidats les républicains udi aux
législatives réunis ce mardi 23 mai à
versailles pour tous l'enjeu n'est pas
simplement locale mais aussi nationale
la représentation des citoyens de leur
territoire sur fond de recomposition
politique c'est un enjeu comme toute
élection
c'est d'ailleurs tout simplement le
respect des électeurs pour les familles
les républicains lui dei qui ont
construit un projet ensemble d'avoir une
représentation parlementaire qui émane
du territoire et c'est le choix qui a
été fait y compris pour les nouveaux
candidats
les neuf députés sortants sont déjà
solidement enracinés dans leur
territoire et les trois nouveaux
candidats sont connus de leurs électeurs
avec une expérience locale de proximité
comme françois-xavier bellamy
maire-adjoint de versailles philippe
brillault maire du chesnay ou ghislain
fournier maire de chatou qui se
présentent dans la 4e circonscription
les candidats que nous proposons aux
yvelinois sont tous des candidats et en
cursus important d'élus locales comme
adjoint au maire pendant une dizaine
d'années comme maire pendant une dizaine
d'années pas simplement pendant quelques
semaines ou quelques mois
la politique c'est pas des diplômes à la
politique c'est de l'expérience des
candidats ancrés dans leur territoire à
l'opposé d'autres candidats qu'ils
jugent son expérience sans mandat
allusion à peine voilée en direction des
candidats dans marche une mise donc sur
leur cohésion pour cette campagne de
terrain face à un électorat très
désorientée après les résultats des
présidentielles il faut beaucoup de
pédagogie beaucoup de terrain pour
expliquer que être dans l'opposition ce
n'est pas s'opposer au redressement de
la france n'aurait aucun sens
ses co construire avec le présent la
république et le gouvernement des
propositions sur le travail sur la
sécurité sur la croissance qui soit dans
le sens au redressement de la france
mais le faire avec nos convictions
les républicains comptent l'emporter
dans les douze circonscriptions un grand
chelem possible avec néanmoins deux
inconnus le score des candidats dans
marche et le front national quasi
certain d'être au second tour dans deux
circonscriptions la 8e et la 9e
deux cas